Heather McDonald knows a lot about this
topic she's written about policing for
many years she's the author of an
upcoming book called when race Trump's
marriage she joins us today to assess
Heather McDonald thank you so much for
coming on this is the tragedy this is
one of them that you predicted I think
how would you assess what we saw in
Memphis
well this makes me long for the days
Tucker when we heard ad nauseam from
Academia that blacks cannot be racist
because racism equals power plus plus
privilege and blacks by definition have
neither of them now we're at the point
where racism is a virtually
non-falsifiable proposition my my
favorite example of this new paradigm is
the claim that the fact that the five
officers in Memphis were indicted for
murder is itself a product of racism so
you know what's an ally to do the only
thing you can do is absolve favored
victim groups of all accountability but
the larger point is that the post-george
Floyd Horrors never stopped coming we
lost thousands more black lives to to
drive by shootings not a single one of
those protested by black lives matter
activists and police departments are now
facing a retention and recruitment
crisis at the same time that the
pressure is escalating yet again to
Higher by race pressure that began under
the Obama Administration and even was
more long-standing well letting race
Trump Merit is always a disaster whether
it's in policing or in medical training
and uh the the premise for this this
diversity hiring is not even true it is
not the case that the more black
officers you have on a force the less
excessive force of brutality you have
the Obama Administration itself found
that in Philadelphia Black and Hispanic
officers were more likely to shoot
unarmed blacks than white officers a
2017 study found that the more black
officers on a force the more black
civilians were killed so this whole
story The Narrative of police racism and
the narrative that getting rid of
Standards will solve our crime or
policing problems is completely false
and it's going to get worse
yeah I mean it none of this has anything
to do with racial Justice these are the
enemies of civilization of Many Colors
um it's not about race it's about
destroying civilization and they're
they're working on it Heather McDonald
um a voice of honesty I appreciate it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight